[Musica]
ho ascoltato prima la testimonianza di
chi mi ha preceduto e parlava dell'altro
l'altro che per tutti noi
nelle contaminazioni positive ci hanno
spiegato un altro come un problema
invece io vorrei parlare dell'altro che
persona che ha dignità ma che
soprattutto e lo dico perché appartengo
al cantiere di dio e dono è dono di dio
e quindi vorrei parlare dell'amore
parlare di contaminazioni positive
vuol dire che parlo della speranza
quella speranza che come diceva
sant'agostino ha due figli
l'indignazione e il coraggio e quindi ho
conosciuto una persona con le palle
scusate signori e qui presenti che si
chiama gesù cristo
un uomo che ha cercato di abbracciare ha
cercato di contaminare il mondo con la
positività un mondo pieno di fulminati
un mondo pieno di persone che si
lamentano sempre che le cose non vanno
bene un mondo a volte pieno sempre di
persone che continuamente ogni giorno
quando si alzano cominciano già a dire
che giornata mi sento sfigato sono una
sfigata
ma questo non va di persone che sono nel
traffico e benedico lo come con le
parolacce gli altri persone che non
hanno più pazienza
vorrei dire a tutte queste persone
coraggio questa terra ha bisogno di
essere abitata da chi da noi noi che
abbiamo un volto
noi che abbiamo una storia questa terra
ha bisogno affinché sia arrivata
soprattutto la speranza quella speranza
che stanno gettando di rubarci e la
speranza che ieri la speranza e concreta
e costruire ponti sono figlio di un
emigrante
sono figlio di questa terra di puglia
sono del salento
vengo dall'africa del nord quando mi
dicono a roma di dove sei
sono un africa del nord e ne sono fiero
di essere africa del nord dividere la
mia terra la mia terra rossa
l'albero di ulivo la terra con cui ho
avuto i miei natali e bene
credo che quattro cose ci devono aiutare
affinché ci siano la contaminazione
positiva nella mia storia nella vostra
vita ama la vita a una e la tua terra
ama i poveri ama gesù cristo
l'omesso dopo gesù cristo apposta va
bene cosa voglio dire ci sono tre punti
importanti nella vita ho incontrato
persone che pensano troppo e che non si
sporcano mai le mani e che aspettano
sempre gli altri che fanno qualcosa
finché poi essi devono essere giudicati
bene don puglisi
mi permetto di citarlo perché un altro
che appartiene e non alla chiesa
incidentata come la chiama papà
francesco
ma una chiesa più viva alla chiesa fatta
di volti fatta di storie a una chiesa
che abbraccia che non discrimina diceva
quelli che riflettono troppo prima di
fare un passo trascorreranno tutta la
vita su un piede solo e che cosa vorrei
dire io mi occupo di ragazzi di strada
di ragazzi che si sono macchiati di
reati pluripregiudicati così li chiamano
nei nei tribunali persone che sono
appartenuti a organizzazioni criminali
come taborra persone come sacra corona
unita
parlo della mia terra persone persone
che si sono affogate persone che non
sempre sono figli dell'amore persone che
non hanno conosciuto la positività di
una strada diversa
e allora a queste persone che cosa
propongo cultura a queste persone che
cosa propongo vita nuova perché è
possibile il cambiamento guardare
l'altro che non mi fa paura
l'altro che invece diventa un modo con
cui mi posso confrontare l'altro che
permetta a me di crescere insieme con
lui l'altro che non diventa bene un
problema
l'altro che non è un problema sociale
l'altro che invece è una risorsa che può
contribuire affinché la nostra amata
terra può cambiare allora amo questa
madre terra e amo la vita con questo
grido che sto sentendo di questo bambino
amo la vita perché la vita oggi la vita
bisogno di persone un po che hanno il
coraggio di gridare di urlare nel senso
positivo perché perché per infondere un
po di positività
e allora
contaminazione positiva vuol dire anche
avere il coraggio di osare e rischiare e
compromettersi ama osare perché abbi il
coraggio di non farti livellare alpi il
coraggio di non lasciarti inquinare
dalle notizie negative che non stai
sperimentando direttamente tu perché le
notizie che ci arrivano
e a volte le comunicazioni che ci fanno
tradiscono già nel nel percorso affinché
arrivano al destinatario
e tu non conosci ma però giudichi ma tu
giudichi senza conoscere allora abitare
la terra significa anche abita la tua
storia dà il senso alla tua vita e dare
senso alla tua vita significa vivi i
valori e quali sono i valori
il valore del rispetto il valore e
soprattutto del dell'accoglienza
il valore della responsabilità un valore
che in disuso la responsabilità come
risposta alla vita come risposta un
impegno di vita affinché le cose possano
cambiare
e poi una cosa importante e voglio anche
concludere se in quella notte quando
incontro un ragazzo di strada ributtato
che faceva le rapine a mano armata e
quando ho chiesto a questo ragazzo ma ai
papà e la mamma mi dice no sono solo il
papà l'ho perso papa si drogava è morto
di overdose della mia mamma mi ha
abbandonato e si è fatto un'altra storia
perché non ce la faceva più chi è andato
a giustamente con un altro uomo
e io vivo per strada io sono solo mi
sento abbandonato bene voglio rivolgere
oggi attira la mia attenzione che non è
la mia attenzione ma in attenzione del
dio che è padre e c'è ancora oggi ti
vuole dire coraggio alzati riappropria
di vite amati accoliti sentiti persona e
guarda avanti
ab lo sguardo che possa soprattutto
irradiare la tua vita con occhi diversi
e questa persona
oggi è cambiata mi voglio rivolgere a te
caro fratello immigrato che si è morto
dal grande destino e che quattro giorni
fa ho fatto un funerale
mi rivolgo a te si chiama appunto lupin
so mi rivolgo a te perché ti ho
considerato un valore aggiunto della mia
vita in questo incontro è con c'è chi
semina paura c'è chi semina odio invece
contaminazione positiva
l'altro è dono per te ogni altro perché
questa terra non ne siamo proprietari e
la abitiamo non con un contratto a tempo
indeterminato tutti siamo provvisori su
questa terra c'era qualcuno che diceva
ricordati che polvere sei e polvere
ritornerai
e ricordati che può essere potente e
prepotente ma te ne uscirai se sei
credente da una chiesa
se non sei credente farà la tua funzione
civile ma te ne uscirai sempre da solo e
se sei stato bravo forse con qualcuno
accanto che piangerà per te ma la vita
ci insegna una cosa importante
l'apertura all'altro e ogni apertura è
un rischio ecco perché osare a rischiare
il rischio questo mondo questa nostra
terra ha bisogno di uomini e donne che
hanno il coraggio di rischiare rischiare
per gli altri affinché ci sia un mondo
diverso e questa positività è possibile
io penso alla mia terra di puglia e
quando parlo della materia di puglia
parla dell'altro gargano fino a santa
maria di leuca parla ovunque
vedo a volte questa terra sempre di più
toccata dalle organizzazioni criminali
questa terra sempre di più contaminata
dal negativo e soprattutto
dall'inquinamento e come giovane voglio
sognare
qualcuno ha detto che credo nelle calde
utopie e sono contento di essere un
sognatore
voglio credere che questa terra può
cambiare perché questa terra deve essere
abitata dai cittadini con la c maiuscola
deve essere abitata da quella
cittadinanza attiva che metta al centro
finalmente il bene comune il bene della
gente contaminazione positiva il bene
della gente non venne degli interessi di
alcuni
capito di tanti credo in questo tempo
che l'unica sfida reale e che appunto e
contaminazione positiva e soprattutto
della fraternita universale dove tutti
si possono incontrare dove nessuno può
mancare il mangiare dove nessun bambino
li possa mancare di poter studiare
perché ci sia cultura perché ci sia
istruzione perché dominare lo diceva se
quando avete buttato nel mondo d'oggi un
ragazzo senza istruzione avete buttato
in cielo un passerotto senza alleati
perché tutti secondo l'articolo 33 34
della costituzione possono avere il
diritto della scuola pubblica
contaminazione positiva credo in un
mondo in cui l'anziano possa essere
rispettato e non possa essere investito
sulle strisce pedonali
credo in un mondo in cui i giovani non
possono più organizzarsi e sentirsi
trattati con un contratto a progetto
credo affinché i giovani possiamo ridare
dignità affinché i giovani si possono
progettare soprattutto della loro vita e
non siano a guinzaglio di questi grandi
marchioni credo in un mondo diverso
contaminazione positiva in mondi cui ci
sia apertura alla rieducazione e al
recupero dove posso vedere ragazzi che
si sono macchiati di reati e quando
avvengono grandi operazioni e le persone
vengono arrestate
vuol dire che lo stato ha fallito
contaminazione positiva agenzie
educative prevenire abitiamo la vita
della gente prima che accadono le cose
credo contaminazione positiva quando
l'omertà possa essere sconfitta dalla
presa posizione delle persone di buona
volontà quando le persone non si
gireranno più dall'altra parte invece
avranno la capacità di guardare con
questi occhi della speranza che sapranno
ascoltare il grido di chi soffre e video
di che solo il grido di coloro che sono
ascoltati da dio e che molto spesso
vengono dimenticati dagli uomini
contaminazione positiva presa di
coscienza contaminazione positiva se c'è
conoscenza ci sarà coscienza
senonchè conoscenza non ci sarà mai
coscienza contaminazione positiva diceva
martin luther king
non ho paura delle parole dei violenti
ma del silenzio degli onesti
contaminazione positiva penso a paolo
borsellino che questo tempo di oggi ne
ha tanto bisogno
si educa con quello che si dice
ancor di più con quello che si fa ma
molto di più con quello che si è
vedete faccio una battuta perdonate
niente contaminazione positiva
noi non possiamo dire se non posso io
come dire essere maestro se non sono
prima testimone il mondo di oggi ha
bisogno contaminazione positiva di
testimoni di persone che dicono e che
fanno di persone che hanno il coraggio
di sognare con la s maiuscola di persone
che guardano al mondo con occhi diversi
che sanno apprezzare la vita e che
mettono al centro la vita e non questo
sporco denaro
questo sporco denaro sapete perché
perché nella maggior parte dei casi e
senza etica contaminazione positiva
diamo moneta agli africani diamo la loro
moneta contaminazione positiva francesi
avete rotto le palle contaminazione
positiva
sapete che vengono colonizzate in quelle
terre no d'africa pochi lo sanno tutti
siamo un po technology photon patrizi
dispiegherà dopo di me siamo con tutti i
telefonini del digitale no ma sapete da
dove le prendiamo queste risorse vengono
dare queste persone di colore ma sono
come l'acqua contaminazione positiva non
verranno fermate da nessuno
sapete perché perché un popolo in
movimento di un momento di persone
persone perché si spostano
contaminazione positiva il terrorismo
l'isis adesso lo dico e mi permetto di
dire che fosse una grande minchiata
sapete come la devono chiamare sistema
internazionale economico per mettere
nelle proprie terre di poter studiare
per poter avere una vita dignitosa e
soprattutto contaminazione positiva
quando parliamo di loro quando parliamo
di organizzazioni criminali di legalità
dobbiamo parlare di la bocca
contaminazione positiva
diamo lavoro perché sentiamo lavoro
rispettiamo la dignità delle persone
contaminazione positiva se credete in
voi stessi nella vostra vita nella
vostra storia e se c'è posto nel dio di
gesù cristo
siate felici perché la felicità è
qualcosa che si persegue e mi dispiace
per il presentatore perché su google
se io dico voglio essere felice attacca
al tram perché non riuscirà la risposta
se vuoi essere felice
vivi la vita amo la vita abita in
pienezza da tua vita se vuoi essere
felice
non lamentatevi grazie
don antonio coluccia grazie
[Applauso]